I think we all work all day and all
night long I do I don't I don't have any
hobbies you know I'm very embarrassed
when people ask me what are my hobbies I
don't have any hobbies I mean it's just
enough to keep up with the things I'm
trying to solve you know you see work on
little puzzles so on and so forth each
puzzle requires attention and so you get
an idea you get your ideas some at
different times sometimes your wife
makes a statement and and you say aha
maybe you're right and so you go off to
your kitchen and and do a little
experiment so you tried it that's that's
the way you make progress if you
continue these things so that's my
recommendation but do not retire do not
meet ire fellas I want